lo que se sabe hasta el momento es que
al menos una persona ha fallecido y diez
han quedado heridos Pero según anunciaba
el presidente
bolodominio Celeste que se refería al
ataque a este museo él aseguraba que
habían personas atrapadas bajo los
escombros y a esta hora continúan la
búsqueda él también se refería a esos
intentos del gobierno de Moscú de atacar
el patrimonio cultural ucraniano desde
el comienzo de la invasión a gran escala
el año pasado como han atacado muchos
museos y centros culturales y también
como atacan a la población civil como es
en este caso de kupians una ciudad que
ha sido importantísima en esta guerra
especialmente en el este del país es
importante para ambas tropas porque es
un punto de comunicación entre el sur y
el norte del este del país estuvo al
comienzo en control de las fuerzas rusas
pero fue retomada otra vez por Ucrania
en esta gran contraofensiva que se llevó
a cabo siempre en el que se retomaron
esas poblaciones de la provincia de
harquit en control de Moscú a pesar de
estar liberada ha sido atacada
sistemáticamente en los últimos meses y
en las últimas semanas por las fuerzas
de Moscú las autoridades de Ucrania
estaban intentando evacuar a la
población especialmente a los niños pero
como sucede en muchas de estas
poblaciones hay muchas personas deciden
quedarse en este caso decían que ya
habían estado en control de los rusos Y
que ahora no iban a abandonar nuevamente
la ciudad del resultado es un ataque a
este importante museo de esta ciudad que
como han dicho las autoridades
ucranianas refuerza Cómo es estos
intentos de las fuerzas de Moscú de
atacar el patrimonio cultural ucraniano
desde el comienzo de esta